[MUSIC]
I think we often see leadership
development as self development.
There's the individual level.
That's where we're really
thinking about you as a person.
You know, a good leader understands what
she has to do to make herself develop,
but there's a second level.
That's the organizational level.
A great leader understands and does what
she has to do to help others to develop.
Most leaders are not
running entire companies.
Most leaders are touching
only a handful of people.
Maybe they don't have any
formal leadership authority but
they do touch their peers and
their colleagues at work.
And those interactions
are opportunities to show leadership.
All of us are challenged
to engage in behaviors that
essentially have leadership
implications for the people around us.
How do your actions as a leader
affect the growth mindset of others?
And then finally,
the third level of analysis is
the environment of the organization,
these includes, society, economy, the
broader culture, the natural environment.
The things each of us do at
work not only matters for
work, they also matter for
the broader world.
Because our actions as leaders,
in order for us to be exceptional,
also will have implications
at that third level.
[MUSIC]
>> Expand your horizons and explore new
ways to elevate your leadership skills.
Explore Stanford's upcoming programs.
[MUSIC]